la emisión está comenzando todos los asistentes están en modo de sólo
escucha ahora sí estaba hablando sólo venga buenas tardes aquí los saludas
sergi sánchez por segunda vez si me dicen que se me oye me véis confirmando
los alumnos a ver qué tal si me oís bien si alguien no me oye escribir por
favor ahí en el chat si todo el mundo oye porque claro si alguien no me oye
no puede contestar que no me oye porque no me está oyendo entonces hay que
preguntarlo por escrito hay que preguntarlo por escrito esto es esto es
de parbulitos de de directo de parbulitos en directo todo el mundo que
me contesta a mí oye porque claro estoy hablando
pues vamos a empezar la clase de hoy esto no es pero es un segundín bueno
recuerdo un poquito la estructura de las clases principio vamos a ir haciendo
lo que lo que tengo preparado que siempre dejó un margen de improvisación que
depende básicamente un poco del feedback me va llegando y en la parte final de la
clase responderemos las preguntas normalmente lo haremos así si en alguna
ocasión pues considero que hay demasiadas preguntas pues otra tanda de
preguntas iremos un poco viendo sobre la marcha recordar que el curso no
acabará hasta que a mí me parezca y eso será de aquí mucho tiempo quiere decir
que tranquilos habrá clases que haremos más material habrá clases que haremos
menos dependiendo ahora clases que haremos sólo sistemas hará clases que
charlaremos más acuerdo es decir vamos un poco al ritmo que requiera el grupo
que es bastante bastante amplio ya comenté en la última a recordar las
preguntas podéis poner podéis escribir está siempre alberto como mínimo ahí
también está pilar incluso victor albergo hay varias personas pendientes
de de atender un poquito todas las preguntas que escribáis y alberto
principio aquellas cosas más inmediatas ya os iré respondiendo si no pues tomará
nota para bien en la ronda de preguntas de la parte final que la haremos tras el
descanso y sí que trataremos de hacer un pequeño parón de 5 como mucho con
muchos 10 minutos pero idealmente 5 y y entonces ahí pos pos vuelta de esta de
este pequeño descanso abordaremos las preguntas ya hay varias pendientes del
día anterior algunas que se han puesto en discord aquellos que todavía no
estéis en el disco los recuerdos recordar que hay un discord que bueno que
para cualquiera pero que hay un grupo reservado de alumnos donde ahí podéis
poner preguntas y un canal que se llama pregunta aquí y ahí podéis preguntar
alguna que a lo mejor no es propiamente del curso pues ya os respondemos pero
normalmente la responderemos en directos porque al final entendemos que pueden
aportar valor al resto de alumnos entonces un poco el criterio también hay
algunas pendientes por email y siempre intentaremos responderlo responderás en
la clase ya comenté el otro día que habían muchas referentes al tema de los
de la construcción de los datos como es algo que me interesa bastante pues voy a
empezar hoy hablando otra vez insistiendo en esto por lo que me gustaría
quedar bastante claro y cómo se construyen los gráficos entendemos qué
diferencias hay en futuro un índice una acción normalmente los problemas de
construcción de gráficos siempre siempre se refieren a los futuros porque
está claro que aún un índice pues no tiene nada que construir ya está
construido no es más que una fórmula operable pero en una fórmula matemática
que recoge pues el comportamiento de una determinada cesta normalmente de
acciones que puede ser de otra cosa y en sí no es operable un índice de acuerdo
aquellos que tengas menos experiencia es lo que tenéis el primer aspecto que
tenéis que tener claro que hay un índice nasdaq pero eso no es operable
recuerdo nosotros necesitamos una un activo que sea operable por ejemplo para
operar el nasdaq pues habría en dos opciones de manera directa que sería el
futuro ahora vamos a hablar bastante de ello y el etf que es el q q q acuerdo
es una acción y que las acciones en la parte de teoría ya hablamos un poquito
de ello pero quizá no tanto profundidad como lo voy a hacer ahora pero en
acciones al final el único componente que podría ajustarse o no es
es el dividendo y ahí es verdad que no hay tanto consenso sobre si hacerlo o no
y de hecho por ejemplo tres station no ofrece la posibilidad de ajustar
acciones decir el dividendo que se pagan por los etf es como cualquier
acción se va descontando del precio y eso no se ajusta y que a menos futuro sí
que ofrece la posibilidad de ajustarlo cambio y otros vendedores de datos que
sí que ofrecen la posibilidad de ajustar una cosa pero no os liais ahora nos
lees ahora con eso vale vamos un poco al tema de los de los futuros de acuerdo
de los futuros bien primero entender por qué ajustamos los futuros de acuerdo y
esto voy a volver a incidir un poco pero con datos recientes y podiendo
interactuar un poquito por ahí recordar que podéis escribir insisto en las
preguntas alberto está ahí atento
en los futuros se genera la necesidad de acuerdo la necesidad de que te unir
distintos vencimientos porque porque los futuros vencen expiran vale por
utilizar una palabra más propia en el caso de acciones de futuros sobre nasda
no johns sp 500 o tax cualquier índice
suelen tener cuatro vencimientos al año pero no único porque el ca 40 por
ejemplo francés vence cada mes de acuerdo es decir hay los hay que vencen
trimestralmente que es lo más usual sobre todo en el caso de acciones pero
los hay también que vencen mensualmente la del ca pero también saliendo de
acciones en el tema de como el que es el petróleo por ejemplo vence cada mes
esto lo bueno es una regulación del propio mercado que cuando nació nació
así normalmente por criterios de seguramente de producción o de
necesidad de variación de precios del que fuera pero pero en su momento pues
partió con x vencimientos pero ya digo lo más usual o los más
conocidos porque son los de acciones sp 500 como os digo nasdaq caos jones
los americanos vencen cuatro veces al año de acuerdo que es decir
trimestralmente quiere decir que cada tres meses el contrato expira y por lo
tanto ahí estamos en la obligación de cambiar si yo estoy operando
es lo que los importa ahora mismo y yo al final me voy a encontrar cuando
llegue ese periodo que tengo que cerrar mi posición en el contrato antiguo y
abrirle en el nuevo ahora mismo por ejemplo para que para que hablemos de un
caso práctico estamos operando el caso el contrato de marzo porque ya venció
diciembre en el caso de índices americanos
vencen tercer viernes tercer viernes del trimestre o sea terceros viernes de
mes del último mes del trimestre es decir tercer viernes de marzo de acuerdo
acabará expirará el contrato de acuerdo es decir en este caso en concreto será
el 15 de marzo de acuerdo 15 de marzo expirarán los futuros que ahora
tienen la letra h esto de las letras como delta luego os lo pongo luego os
lo pongo vale para no sabíamos ahora de cuáles son todas las letras h es marzo
vale esto nuevamente es así
h es marzo igual que m es junio junio esos dos pasos son las más usuales como
el primer paso es ingresar en septiembre si usted le hace un clic aquí z y va a llevar
esos son los cuatro principales muchos futuros coinciden con esos cuatro aunque
hay los cargaran discos me las tengo que mirar
así que me las sé porque son las típicas preguntas me las tengo que mirar
entonces bien ahora estamos contestando operando en una pestaña del navegador
h 24 estas estas las letras ahora mismo es lo de menos estos nomenclatura de cada
es bastante estándar pero puede ser que cada plataforma tenga sus matices sus
maneras de referirse al de acuerdo lo que importa es el vencimiento de marzo es
el que ahora es lo que llevamos el front el que el mercado está operando como
principal como se sabe esto bueno porque es el que tiene más volumen y por
experiencia ya lo sabes ahora mismo no lo sabes nunca pero cuando empiezas a
operar pues ya lo sabes este tipo de cosas que parecen cuando empiezas a
recorrer complicadas son siempre igual de acuerdo no cambia siempre la misma
rutina tercer viernes de mes que acaba siempre es la letra h y siempre es la letra u
m que no tiene más que tenerlo apuntado sabérselo y ya está aquí con el
tiempo ya es podemos decir uso para el costumbre y lo mismo los símbolos de la
plataforma o lo mismo que los gráficos veis yo tengo aquí abajo que es la
manera en que tres sesiones de información que le llamamos rolos y lo
tengo creado para eso para ver los rolos que hago comparo el vencimiento
podemos decir que va a expirar con el futuro ahora queda mucho ahora estamos
en marzo y por eso que la derecha ahora lo voy a hacer grande para que lo veáis
mejor si es un dispositivo pequeño pues veis un gráfico por ejemplo que estos
son velas de un minuto en el nasdaq es que apenas tiene apenas tiene datos
porque porque esto es junio de acuerdo sí que va haciendo algún contrato pero
uno sabe apenas apenas nadie opera esto hoy en día puede haber algún motivo para
operarlo si puede haber algunas estrategias tipo calendar pero son más
de commodities que de web tardar unos 5 minutos puede y de hecho como es no
aparece un contrato mueve el acuerdo algún trato que mueve hoy por ejemplo
vería así lo que llevamos en sesión el contrato de junio ha movido a
200 bienvenidos al curso de latín de trading este va a ser el módulo número uno
poquita cosa poquita cosa en cambio el ok luego del disclaimer actual es como el
marzo pues lleva 327 mil por 100 y no dependas el tray se hace en importante
la medida que vaya avanzando que tener una vida equilibrada es decir y igualando
vale pero fijaros en un detalle importante a abrirme un poco no me
abierto el lapicito sólo lo que quiero que vea es cómo se comporta las cosas en
la pantalla pero ya lo tengo aquí ya lo tengo aquí preparado a ver color por
ejemplo amarillo amarillo y vamos a ir con un puntito mediano este es el módulo
tres del curso aquí está compañía en los que los precios vale ya lo digo yo
por si no se ve muy grande acuerdo marzo ahora mismo se refiere a 15 mil
17 mil 577 78 más o menos y el siguiente está a 17 mil 800 más de 200 puntos por
encima el índice el índice recordar el índice que replican todos es decir esto
es el futuro al final sigue a un subyacente cuál es el subyacente
y aparte es el nasdaq 100 a 17 mil 469 también es decir por debajo esto es normal es usual
y lo que no es estable podemos decir es cuanto por encima el futuro normalmente va a estar por
encima va a estar por encima del contado indican que sobre todo un contra más alejado esté de la
fecha de vencimiento porque bueno porque el tiempo vale dinero que hablamos del valor temporal del
dinero aquel que no lo haya visto es el tema 0 del curso que no corresponde a término agonómico
pero pues para para aquellos que no tuvieran idea pues decidimos hacer ese tema y algunos nos habéis
preguntado por qué hicimos eso y a lo mejor no hemos hablado de órdenes bueno hemos hablado de
órdenes de hecho hemos hablado pero es verdad que siempre puedes hablar más de todo y nunca sabes
dónde cortar de acuerdo y bueno pues sí podríamos haber mejor hablado alguna cosa más he dejado un
manual por ahí de análisis técnico para aquel que quiera saber cosas de análisis técnico que no
que yo que sé que es una tendencia de cosas de tipo pero bueno sí que podríamos haber hablado
alguna cosa más de órdenes para no iniciados no pero bueno volviendo al tema del dinero el
motivo 1 es ese el tiempo vale dinero y eso viene reflejado sobre todo por el tipo de interés que
sabéis que es variable que hay momentos de tipos más alto y de tipos más bajo ahora mismo pues
estamos en si no recuerdo mal hablo de memoria en el cuatro y medio cuatro y medio alberto eeuu
estamos a cuatro y medio no tipos en eeuu vale pues ahora estamos a cuatro y medio entonces
pues claro hace tres años era muy inferior y por lo tanto la diferencia era menor porque el tiene
el tiempo valía menos dinero de acuerdo el tiempo valía menos dinero ahora el tiempo vale más dinero
porque los tipos de interés no vamos a entrar ahora porque ni demás no no sobre todo este de
este curso pero el tiempo ahora vale más dinero que hace tres años entonces por lo tanto los
futuros recogen ese impacto hay otros valores otras cosas que influyen si por supuesto los
dividendos que pagan las acciones vale y básicamente es eso de acuerdo básicamente es eso el tiempo y
los dividendos que pagan las acciones básicamente es eso el coste y el coste de financiación que
el tiempo entonces eso es el motivo por el que futuro suele estar por encima el cuánto está por
encima ya os digo es algo que es variable y como veis el índice está a 17 400 y pico marzo está a
17 600 y junio está a 17 800 si vamos más atrás pues seguramente estará más esto normalmente es
así no entramos ahora en si esto a veces invierte no da igual esto es lo normal de acuerdo esto es
lo normal lo habitual porque por este componente temporal que os decía vale por ese componente
temporal que os decía vale entonces claro como yo tengo un vencimiento si yo quiero hacer análisis
quiero hacer sistemas quiero hacer backtest yo tengo que esto que veis ahora es solo el contrato
de marzo y como veis pues tiene unos días que tiene volumen que lo veis abajo pero a partir de
que empezó a ser el front para atrás como veis apenas tiene volumen y ya llega a un punto que
incluso solo tiene tics a mí esto no me sirve para trabajar entonces de aquí viene la necesidad de
unir de acuerdo distintos contratos y construir un gráfico continuo vale de esto viene de que los
futuros expiran imaginaos el que expira cada mes pues pues todavía peor vale entonces cuál es el
criterio para unir bueno hay varios pero en general el consenso bien utiliza un criterio bastante
coherente y sencillo que es o bien el que tiene más volumen o bien el que tiene más open interest
esto esto es así decir a mí a mí que me interesa operar bueno aquel que el mercado concibe la front
y cuál es el front pues el principal pues a aquel que está haciendo más volumen de acuerdo ahora no
hay duda vale como a medida que nos acercamos a la expiración nuevamente por uso de costumbre en
10 5 6 7 días hay siempre ahora por ejemplo el que normalmente es 5 6 días estoy a plaza de la
fecha de expiración es decir ese tercer viernes me metí en tres no aquí tengo un indicador que
compara para ganar otro y me va a medir ahora aquí lo ponen muy bien voy a intentar hacerlo
hacerlo grande pero está en los 224 bueno es lo que marca este indicador donde empieza esto
simplemente resta uno contra otro a hacerse presente y es que resta uno contra otro y además de alguna
cuando está acá pero cuando yo es que sólo va en tiempo real y no respeto mi riesgo recuerde que
mi riesgo es 380 aquí se empieza a descontrolar mis aires y aquí yo combino esto fíjense que
es esto al final tiene una parte con una línea recta que es esto no estoy persiguiendo lo pues
pero algo interesante en la diferencia entre el vídeo dando el solo 20 real en el 52 y por lo
tanto por eso no me que es este punto de acá y no me estaba marcando está debido a ser hasta que
no lo he abierto y está debido de ser fíjense que es algo bastante parecido con el de arriba
es la combinación de algo exactamente lo mismo porque se mide la diferencia esta entrada por
sí sola ahora que está bien y esta entrada por sí sola estaba bien siempre y cuando respetar
lo que está mal es no salir acá y agregar acá porque me sale de la posición entonces
como unimos estos contratos de acuerdo aquí es donde vendría la problemática y donde he visto
que hay bastante bastante confusión esto lo hablamos en la clase bueno en la parte de
pero estaba explicado en el vídeo de aspectos previos si no recuerdo mal no si lo hablamos
en aspectos pero es en el punto 5 del desarrollo de nuestro sistema vale sería 511 512 no me
acuerdo detalle que no tengo aquí los vídeos delante pero sí que era el 5 aspectos previos
que hablaba tecnología y ahí hablaba también de esto de los futuros de teniendo los gráficos
continuos porque rolamos bien buenos días esto será un tutorial para das trader ok esta es la
plataforma recién descargada entonces les quiero mostrar un poco lo que debe configurar o lo que
lea no enseñe forward voy a enseñar los forward que los he construido con tic data que tenemos
nosotros la posibilidad de hacerlo entonces he construido un par de gráficos continuos nosotros
tenemos datos comprados que esto me ha preguntado alguien ya les había contestado si hacía falta no
de verdad hoy en día no hace falta no es algo imprescindible no nos no no va a haber una gran
diferencia hoy en día recuerdo porque ya llevamos muchos años de buena calidad de datos en la mayoría
de eventos el problema es que cuando yo empecé ahora sí pues seguimos haciendo porque al final
pues quieres hacer las cosas con doble che podemos decir no aquí tengo algunos muy actualizados
otros que los tengo antiguos porque al no usarlos nos actualizó pero esto con este
programa nosotros editamos tenemos la posibilidad de construir el gráfico continuo de distintos
criterios con distintas ordenaciones pero ya digo es igual esto entonces aquí por un lado tengo yo
he aplicado un sistema cualquiera creo que son unas bandas de de bollinger un poco igual que ya
simplemente pues enseñaros para que veáis un poco la diferencia si es simplemente compra
con bollinger van y cierra pero por arriba es decir poco haber ratio para aquellos que sepáis
de que hablo es un poco a ver de izquierda a derecha no sé esto como lo veis de grande pero
bueno voy a intentar explicarlo lo mejor posible para aquellos que lo veáis en pequeño espero
vale entonces aquí de izquierda a derecha yo tengo los dos gráficos de la izquierda es decir
estos este y este vale son gráficos forward vale son gráficos forward el de arriba es un
forward por diferencia ahora ahora explico ahora explico y el de abajo es un forward por rati
que es forward o que es backward que son los dos criterios los he he construido porque con
un ejemplo se va a ver muy se va a ver muy bien no forward quiere decir que yo parto yo cuando
construyo un gráfico como habéis visto tengo que unir de cientos vencimientos parto de algún punto
lo normal lo normal es partir del inicio del contrato pero no tiene por qué podría iniciar
en el inicio del año pasado pero lo normal es hacerlo en el inicio del contrato para eso
ya partimos que necesito toda la base de datos entonces si tengo toda la base de datos en este
caso el nasdaq es de 1 de julio del 99 vale yo la tengo voy a abrir ahora este vale para que lo
para que lo veamos me parece que en algún momento voy a tener que reiniciar 3 stationes porque no
lo he hecho aquí al empezar y francamente me he equivocado porque se me va a saturar cien por
cien empiezo aquí en el en el 1 de julio vale y ahí empieza empieza si yo hago forward de acuerdo
en el inicio de acuerdo que es ese 1 de junio que os digo el precio empieza en su valor real es decir
el que tuvo ese día de acuerdo que tuvo ese día veis aquí open 2000 abrió 2329 con 50
x movimiento vale empieza ahí y lo que hago es los ajustes que haya que hacer que ahora
los explico que ahora los explico vale los hago hacia adelante es decir os sumo el resto pero en
el siguiente contrato no en el anterior de acuerdo es decir el único que refleja el valor real que
tuvo en ese día es este el del inicio pues vamos a suponer que fue estamos hablando del 99 que
era julio por lo tanto estaría operando septiembre pues que era septiembre del 99 el contrato de
septiembre del 99 pues ese contrato en este gráfico refleja su valor real a partir de ahí todos los
siguientes están ajustados vale están ajustados antes que lo tenía preparado lo tenía pensado
pero ahora al empezar no lo he hecho porque os quería enseñar primero que os va a ayudar a entenderlo
mejor vale bien bien lo que he dicho es correcto pero me vuelvo ahora al de medio para explicaros
para explicaros la cosa que os va a ayudar a aquellos que todavía no me estáis siguiendo vale el no
ajustado vale este de aquí abajo ahora os voy a enseñar es el no ajustado es decir este simplemente
une todos los contratos pero sin hacer ningún ajuste vale este por tanto refleja todos los
precios de los contratos reales porque no hay ningún ajuste qué problema tiene que esta
diferencia que habéis visto que ahora veíamos por ejemplo en el caso este real actual no era
de 240 puntos o si ahora mismo en este momento cuando llegue el vencimiento veremos cuál es
pero bueno igual pongamos que son 200 puntos pues en el momento de unir esos dos contratos pues se
aparecen con 200 contratos con 200 puntos de diferencia vale este todos los precios que
tienes son reales pero habrá algunos algunos gaps sobre todo cuando hay pues como ahora la actualidad
vamos a verlo ahora la actualidad y como hay pues unos tipos altos pues hay momentos cierto de un
gap fuerte no sé si era este el vencimiento el último vencimiento ha sido el de diciembre que
fue el día 15 1 2 3 15 de diciembre vale 15 de diciembre aquí pensó aquí bueno no no se ve
mucho acá porque igual ya vino a abrir ya vino arriba y a veces no se ve el gap porque
depende cómo venga el mercado pero ya os digo que hay gap de acuerdo hay gap porque bueno hay gap
simplemente lo que hay es una unión entre contratos y bueno la unión perdón perdón la unión se hace
cinco días antes es este gap es este gap porque la unión es cinco días cinco días antes a ver
que alberto me levanta la mano tienes razón si tengo que sólo tengo para que se vea los sistemas
pero aquí no me interesa que se vea los sistemas entonces vamos a poner las velas ahí perdón
esto lo vale entonces todo lo que se veía como como es cinco días antes el vencimiento último
que aquí es un ejemplo no importa sólo para que podáis seguirlo bien pues sería 15 1 2 3 4
efectivamente este es el este gap es el vencimiento es el enlace de acuerdo entre diciembre que se
acaba y empieza marzo de acuerdo porque acaba diciembre empieza marzo que es el que está ahora
entonces eso es si no ajustas pasa eso los precios son los correctos a todos los gráficos que enlazas
los ves al precio que cotizaron en su momento pero se genera una distorsión fruta fruto de este enlace
distinto tú dices bueno vale pero si los precios son correctos porque hay gente que lo pregunta
además como criterio y hasta entiendo como casi todo es debatible si los precios son los
correctos y porque realmente lo ajustamos lo ajustamos porque esa diferencia de esos 200
puntos no es fruto de la oferta de la demanda no es real que el mercado habrá un 200 puntos por
encima de acuerdo el mercado habría plano probablemente las acciones que al final hacen
subir al índice no estaban subiendo por tanto tú ahí no ganabas 200 puntos vale si venías largo
en ese gráfico continuo si tú venías largo ese día no deberías ganar nada en cambio si no ajustas
en ese gap de pronto ganas 200 200 puntos no es real no estás ganando 200 puntos entonces tú ahí
lo que tienes que hacer es cerrar en uno y abrir en el otro y seguir la posición y el precio subirá
o bajará esto si ahora lo vemos voy a hacer lo que me ha comentado alberto en todos porque es
verdad que así no se ve un cariño a ver que esto antes como mucho pero poder dedicar menos de una
hora porque quería enseñaros una plantear al menos una estrategia hoy ahora mira voy a ponerme
una cosa que me permite verlos el mismo día en distintos días y acercar fijaros me voy a acercar
en todos bueno me da igual es igual estos que están ajustados he oído un pito que pasa a
parece que es el discord pero lo cierro perdón porque no se cierra bien entonces lo que decía
aquí ahora yo marco este día y ese mismo día me lo está marcando todos los gráficos fijaros en
el de arriba es como no no no hay ese gap de verdad lo voy a marcar también arriba para que lo
lo podáis seguir los círculos ahora con el que se queda gráfico pero aquí veis no que es el
mismo no hay no hay no hay no hay gap de acuerdo porque el de arriba es el índice el de arriba este
es el índice de acuerdo este de aquí es el índice este es el índice y este es no ajustado el de
arriba el índice el de abajo no ajustado entonces veis el índice realmente no se ve ese gap entonces
las acciones no subieron entonces si yo no ajusto y vengo largo ese día tengo 200 puntos y si vengo
corto pues pierdo 200 puntos no es verdad de ahí parte de la necesidad de ajustar tratar de
reflejar lo más cercano a la realidad que no es fácil siempre ahora vais a ver que pueden haber
diferencias entonces la necesidad de solucionar este que ya os digo hay distintas soluciones y
adaptas la que pues en principio es mejor pero hay varias vale vale ahora vuelvo a donde estaba
antes queda claro el índice arriba abajo el no ajustado aquí os decía que los dos de la
izquierda tienen ajuste por forward y por eso os decía que en ese caso el único contrato que
refleja el precio que tuvo la realidad es el primero porque el ajuste se hace hacia adelante
de acuerdo se empieza se empieza en cero y se va cero quiero decir cero en el tiempo no en el
primer contrato y a partir de ahí para adelante ese diferencia que haya se va se va añadiendo o
restando y por eso veis que no se lo veis pero os lo digo yo si no el precio del contrato forward
ajustado por diferencia que es el de arriba a la izquierda vale marca 15 mil 900 puntos esto
está todo a cierre de viernes para no no liar digamos para no meter hoy ajuste de bienes y
el de abajo que es por guard ajustado por ratio está a 12 mil 300 es decir el de arriba 15 mil
900 el de abajo 12 300 cuando el índice está a 17 400 vale es decir el forward tiene ese
problema por eso no solemos usarlo para operar ahora ahora os diré cuando se usa porque porque
como que no nos gusta o sea es como un poco intuitivo aparte que en tiempo real plantearía
un problema de ajuste sabía que a todos los precios en tiempo real estará ajustándolos
vale habría que estar ajustando en tiempo real en cambio en el en el backward que es el que solemos
usar pasa justo lo contrario que el único contrato que refleja el precio bien es el actual y por eso
vais a ver que bueno hay una pequeña diferencia hay una pequeña diferencia pero es no no no lo
tengáis en cuenta porque es porque como el índice acaba a la hora en punto todos se acaban ahora en
punto y al no haber liquidación pues veo que el último tic que refleja el de el de tic data con
el de tres eso pues hay un hay 050 diferente pero bueno ya digo ahora mismo es es que demos no
quedemos nos que es anecdótico porque porque aquí hay unos que son de tic data y hay dos futuros que
son con los precios de tres seis porque usa un poco los todos pues para ahora hablaros de ello
para poder hablaros bien sigo los en la izquierda os decía que eran los for war los de la derecha
pues lógicamente son los backward vale y eso sí que reflejan el precio al que está ahora el futuro
es decir antes os enseñaba que el precio aunque se está en tiempo real y por eso hay una leve
diferencia este que veis aquí que está a 15 590 vale bueno pues es este acuerdo este es el mismo
precio lo que pasa que como os digo es esta viernes es esta viernes y por eso pues no es el
mismo vale porque se nos está moviendo si ahora lo activará tiempo real pues se vería se vería
y está pero este precio de aquí es tiempo real para se me entienda es todos estos son futuros este
este es el contado este es el índice vale pero tendría esa diferencia que os he explicado pero
los dos de la los dos de la derecha y el de abajo de medio estos son futuros que están ajustados
mediante backward y por lo tanto el precio actual es el correcto vale es el correcto los anteriores
pueden estar ajustados si hay diferencia entre los contratos que ya habéis visto que suele haberla
y ahora con los tipos de interés que tenemos pues es bastante alta cuando hay pocos intereses pues
a veces es muy pequeña la diferencia a veces es muy muy muy pequeña sobre todo en futuros
de vencimiento mensual puede ser nada muy pequeño pero ahora con tipos altos suele ser mayor entonces
los backwards reflejan el precio actual y por eso un poco son los que usamos repito actualmente 17
500 en cambio los forward están 15 900 y 12 300 dependiendo si ajustas diferencia o ratio ahora
entro en eso ahora entro en que es diferencia o ratio eso también he visto que que ha explicado
al explicarlo casi ha provocado más más confusión que otra cosa vale porque porque hay dos maneras
de ajustar hay dos maneras en cuanto a la manera en que ajustamos como he dicho forward y backward
y luego hay dos maneras en cuanto a qué hacemos con esa diferencia esos 200 puntos que os he
enseñado aquí que ahora más o menos viene uno vamos a suponer que ahora arrolláramos pues lo
224 puntos a suponer que fuera ahora 224 puntos que se hace con esos 224 puntos bueno al final
si yo tengo que mantener el actual en el caso backward de acuerdo en el caso backward si yo
tengo que mantener el actual como real si tengo que mantener el actual como real y el que viene
por encima el futuro el siguiente viene por encima la única manera de hacer eso es subir a
los anteriores de acuerdo en el caso backwards lo que yo hago es aumentar lo siguiente pero esto lo
hacen los programas automáticamente pero qué hace para evitar este gab que veis aquí este gab lo
que hace es sumarle 220 puntos a toda la base de datos y eso lo hace en cada momento que hay
un vencimiento en ese momento claro eso provoca que los precios históricos sean muy distintos
es decir veíais aquí en el en el no ajustado veíais en el no ajustado el precio inicial que
era 2300 por ahí no 2329 50 ese era el inicio 2329 50 claro imaginaros ahora en el ajustado
backward ese precio cuál es ese precio es 3300 es otro precio 3300 en el ajustado por ratio y en
el ajustado por diferencia es 3900 es otro precio es otro precio porque pues porque ha ido sumando
restando normalmente sumando normalmente sumando pero puede ser sumando restando
a toda la base la base de datos esto esto se entiende claro esto distorsionó los precios
pero mantiene la relación el problema cuál es que sólo mantiene la relación este día de acuerdo
es decir el día el día que el día que hay el rolo el día que se unen cuando hablo de rolo hablo
de unión vale otra cosa es la operativa en el mercado no nos lees ahora estamos hablando de
construcción de gráficos son operativos el día que yo uno ese día mantengo la relación es decir
yo anulo esa diferencia por lo tanto ese día sí que he mantenido la relación bien el problema es
que claro como sólo una vez cada tres meses pues las relaciones se pueden ir alterando durante todo
el mes y esa diferencia no es estable durante todo el mes y pues bueno sí que es verdad que los
gráficos lógicamente se parecen pero no son iguales no son iguales decir todos estos gráficos dan
resultados ligeramente distintos de un sistema aplicado y ahora lo mostraremos dan resultados
ligeramente distintos pero son ligeramente distintos son ligeramente visitos son no deben
ser radicalmente visitos pero esta es el motivo por el que se provocan ajustes y por la que hay
distintas maneras que pasa con el caso forward vale que como habéis visto ahora mismo no tiene
precios reales no tiene precios reales es decir ahora mismo el forward el nasa ajustado forward
hasta el viernes marca 15 900 si lo ajustamos por diferencia y marca 12 300 si lo hemos ajustado
por rato es decir mucho menos por mucho menos porque porque como el ajuste es hacia adelante
aquí pasa lo contrario si cuando llega el contrato nuevo el contrato nuevo viene por encima se entiende
no viene por encima esto esto lo hemos visto no viene por encima lo vemos aquí vale viene por
encima este está por encima de este es el futuro entonces yo tengo que unir esto con esto y quiero
mantener la relación que tengo que hacer subir subir al anterior por eso y por eso
perdón tengo que subir al anterior pero estoy hablando del forward si lo hago hacia adelante
que tengo que hacer bajar el siguiente o bajo el anterior que es cuando lo hago backward o perdón
o subo el anterior cuando lo hago backward o bajo el siguiente cuando lo hago forward
para compensar esos 200 puntos porque al final simplemente el backward o forward esto entiendo
para aquel que no se ha familiarizado es un poco lioso simplemente indica cuál es el que se queda
con el precio correcto entendido si yo justo backward el que se queda corriente el que se
queda correcto es este si yo justo forward el que se queda correcto es este pensando suponer
que hoy hay vencimiento y esos 220 puntos los tengo que compensar o bien se los resto a uno
bien se los sumo a otros no hay más y por eso por eso ahora aquí veis que el forward en el precio
actual vale mucho menos en el precio forward vale menos y en cambio en el ajuste backward el
primero vale más el actual vale lo que tiene que el precio actual porque es el real vale esto se
va siguiendo alberto que vale pues si hay alguna de esto si esto quizá que sí que lo vamos
resolviendo porque lo quiero cerrar este tema me gustaría cerrarlo así que vamos tratando de
resolverlo si ves que aporta si no lo respondes tú vale ahora lo vemos eso ahora lo vemos
joaquín si os voy a ir leyendo os voy a ir leyendo porque esto me gustaría cerrarlo sabes no ir
recurrientemente a esto porque si no no avanzaremos vale no avanzaremos y luego ya pues si hay dudas
podemos responderlo fuera de clase en el problema en ese que tranquilo que te respondemos pero sí
que a nivel de clase me gustaría cerrar esto de acuerdo no volver más porque si no nos vamos a
quedar aquí en continuamente que ya entiendo que hay gente que provoque dudas pero la si si
pos si pos clase alguien no lo entiende yo me comprometo a explicárselo si hace falta en una
clase privada pero pero por eso voy a mirar un poco las las las preguntas vale antonio comenta
antonio comenta voy a ir leyendo en marc estamos viéndolo o sea lo que lo que pides no sé si es
que lo has pedido antes pero podemos ver un ejemplo práctico de cómo ajustar lo estamos viendo lo
estamos viendo cómo ajustar es decir tú no tienes que ajustar es decir esto al final tienes que
conseguir un software que te ajuste un proveedor de datos que ya te ajuste pero pero yo creo que
esto es básico saberlo porque cuando te encuentras con un futuro tienes que saber cuál te encuentras
y por qué y qué problemas tiene uno y otro y si puedes elegir que en el caso de tres son puedes
pues que tengas criterio para elegir tres se son ya da uno por defecto para mí no es el mejor pero
da uno y si lo usas tampoco tampoco va a ser el fin del mundo es decir me explico pero bueno
estamos aprendiendo te digo agonímico entonces mucho te digo agonímico se desarrolla en futuros
también acciones pero mucho mucho en futuros casi que más y por lo tanto pues creo que eso
es importante saberlo es importante saberlo pero tú entre ese hecho por ejemplo tienes un gráfico
continuo uno que es la roba en ecu por ejemplo se abre uno pero estos estos que os he abierto
yo son personalizados ahora os enseñaré eso a seguir porque puede que algunas preguntas vayan
cayendo un poco en la en las respuestas vale entonces de momento hemos visto lo que es un
me interesa que entendáis no preguntéis más allá de acuerdo es decir centrarnos en lo que
estoy explicando vale es decir forward backward de acuerdo las diferencias de precios no vayáis más
allá porque ahora voy a ir yo y a lo mejor ya os respondo vale es decir que quede claro que es un
backward que queda claro que es un que es forward porque se ajuste que quede claro esta diferencia
entre entre precios vale bien entonces esto como os digo en el caso y otras plataformas suelen
dar un continuo aquí tengo uno de tres session que concretamente es el arroba en ecu igual 105
xn vale pero esto si yo en vez de abrir esto hubiera abierto el en ecu la tecla puedo perfectamente
hacer y va a tener sólo leves diferencias con este bueno le va a tener si podemos decir leves
porque porque el en ecu tres eso para mí bueno digamos que suele rolar uno o dos días tarde pero
bueno tampoco es crítico y lo sigue haciendo por diferencia lo sigue haciendo por diferencia que
en mi opinión a medida que van pasando los años pues se vuelve peor es un poco mejor hacerlo por
ratio aún no os he explicado en detalle estaba en ello cuando me he puesto con las preguntas ahora
ahora me lo he pasado las diferencias entre ajuste por diferencia y ajuste por ratio es
simplemente es simplemente el concepto de o bien sumar y restar o multiplicar dividir es tan sencillo
como eso o el mismo que la escala lineal o escala logarítmica vale escala lineal al final refleja
el cambio en puntos y el cambio la semi logarítmica refleja el cambio en porcentaje pues es un poco
lo mismo vale en diferencia es exactamente en diferencia es decir o bien sumo o bien resto a
todos los datos los 220 puntos que decía que había de diferencia vamos a suponer que el día en que
tiene que hacer el programa el rolo el empalme perdón el enlace hay 220 puntos pues se lo suma
y punto a todo o se lo resta y hasta eso es por diferencia y cuando es por ratio bueno pues ratio
lo que hace es dividir los dos precios es como si fuera un porcentaje entiende eso no es decir si
tiene ahora más o menos es igual el precio exacto 178 30 y tiene 17 600 pues divido uno
por otro y el ratio es 1 0 1 3 1 0 1 3 0 6 8 por ese ratio multiplícola como estás soy sergi
sánchez de ser sánchez se entiende simplemente eso es un ajuste meramente matemático es el efecto
de o bien sumar restar o bien multiplicar dividir porque es mejor multiplicar dividir bueno por lo
que hemos hablado muchas veces en el curso de los porcentajes de la escala de la diferencia
de precios entre el nasdaq y etcétera no que no es lo mismo a 2000 como habéis visto al inicio del
contrato que hay 17 mil y cada 100 puntos si yo le quito 100 puntos de ahora 200 puntos de ahora
le quito 200 al contrato de inicio también porque lo que hago es restar toda la base de datos entonces
bienvenidos todos más correcto gracias por su paciencia es más correcto pequeñas dificultades
aquí tratando de empezar en aquellos contratos que van a negativo vale por ese efecto eso evita
que vayan a negativo o sea todo tiene sus excepciones pero en términos generales es
mejor porque por lo que os digo porque ese porcentaje y el porcentaje mantiene mejor
la relación porque esos 200 puntos se los suma todo el histórico pasado como habéis visto que
era 3000 y pico pero ahora el siguiente se los va a volver a sumar y el 3300 inicios la 3500
o sea si ahora ahora esto va a quedar grabado así que es fácil es fácil verlo aquí hemos visto no
todavía está cargando porque esto claro esto muchos años y además en el gráfico intradiliario
si yo ahora quien el en la plataforma de que está ajustado para la apertura de su cuento por
ratio vale este de aquí abajo estaba ajustado para por ratio entonces al principio cuando tenía
tenía 3311 el de arriba estaba ajustado para guard por diferencia vale y tenía un precio inicial de
3900 bueno fijaros ese en apertura del día 1 de julio del 99 vale esto queda grabado 1 de julio
del 99 es 3948 con 25 vale esa es la apertura de ese día en ajuste por diferencia en el contrato
en eq igual 105 xc vale arroba en eq igual 105 xc en este contrato 1 de julio 99 apertura 3948
cuando venza marzo veréis como ese precio sube y será seguramente 4100 si llega a 200 puntos
el contrato la diferencia entre ambos vale sino pues lo que sea cambiará siempre cambia entonces
claro yo le voy metiendo 200 puntos a todo el histórico pero 200 puntos ahora bien pero 200
puntos cuando está 3000 entonces claro es mejor hacer por 103 por 103 que es lo que os decía que
el ratio se entiende no es como más ortodoxo más más ortodoxo vale bien entonces esto que
efecto provoca bueno yo al final tengo aquí un ejemplo tengo aquí un sistema metido cualquiera
que es igual que es un churro es bowling era saco no importa se ha puesto este porque no sé
por qué se era lo tenía metido y está vale no no los enseñaron para tecar a medida de pantalla
voy a aprovechar el descanso para cerrar el 3d station porque se me va a tomar viento
en esta se me está yendo a tomar viento tanto cuando le cargas uno de los este año este año
que muchos habláis de las plataformas yo decía que es que no es tan importante nosotros usamos
este son multichars visual char metatrader y habíamos usado hace muchos años web lab y
este año como se me den las cosas a lo mejor hasta metemos otra vez web lab en la en la
dinámica de trabajo porque era un software que iba que iba muy bien y puede ser que
metamos web lab en la dinámica de trabajo así que al final como os dije siempre estás con
nuevas plataformas nuevos lenguajes y esa venceros a que volveremos a hacer otra vez bueno a lo que
iba estaba aquí con este con este sistema tratando de enseñarlos lo que digo que no importa esto no
importa me da igual me da igual vale lo que quiero que veáis es que todo cargado igual con
exactamente los mismos inputs el mismo coste todo igual misma gestión monetaria aquí por ejemplo
tiene un resultado de menos 67 millones porque es que lo cargado desde el principio era positivo
he cargado los últimos 10 años pero he querido meterle más años y ahí he visto que y por no
volverlo a cargar todo pues es igual el importe es lo de es lo de menos es verdad que el profit
factor no cambia tanto tampoco es se parece parece bastante es decir los cambios no son
súper dramáticos pero veis arriba era menos 67 abajo es menos 57 si vemos este aquí a la derecha
va a ser parecido este va a ser parecido menos 42 y aquí menos 58 vale en todo caso están estos
de la derecha son profit factor de 0 90 los de la izquierda y no 0 90 y no 0 90 el no ajustado
siempre es el que es peor 0 88 vale bueno no es que siempre sea el peor es el peor en cuanto a
realista vale no ajustar sólo es recomendable en aquel caso que operéis un sistema muy muy
intradiliario y que al final podáis asumir cerrar posiciones totalmente cuando por código se acaba
el contrato y empezaron el nuevo entonces puede tener sentido y puede ser hasta preferible porque
entonces sí que evitas totalmente las distorsiones vale evita solamente las distorsiones tener en
cuenta que es lo que os digo los lo bueno de los los de las vencimientos y todo esto es que son
totalmente estables es decir son conocidos previamente es decir no no es ninguna incertidumbre
no es algo que no pueda programar yo puedo fácilmente en un código programar que el tercer
viernes de cierre de trimestre a x hora de los sistemas y reposiciones si quiero decir esto esto
es perfectamente viable vale claro en sistemas que sean medianamente suces y que siguen posiciones
a lo largo del día esto no es posible y como vamos a ver vamos a empezar sobre todo en este
tipo de sistemas pues por eso creía oportuno dejar acabar de acordar todo esto sobre los
decimientos o sea sobre los contratos y demás vale que ahora sí que voy a repasar las preguntas a
ver si queda algo que complementar vale lo que está en banderita es lo que tengo que mirar
lo que tengo banderitas por aquí tiene una persona pero topless abajo me miro si responder
a corto y de al pie no entiendo jose dolén lo que me dices vale entiendo que se ajusta
eligiendo el gráfico correcto no entiendo a ver si me puedes aclarar los datos del re por
antonio de verdad no importa no importa no importa es que nada no no importa nada
jordy te aclaro esto de las letras si vale tienes razón esto esto lo era lo que me faltaba pero
faltaba y se me olvidaba así que gracias por tu aportación bien esto os he cargado que por cierto
he acabado el arroba en eq el arroba en eq el arroba es el arroba o sea todos los futuros
continuos entre esos y en muchas plataformas se identifican por una ropa pero si no pues hay
que ver cómo se identifican en ese software ese proveedor lo que fuera vale el gráfico
continuo se arroba en eq entonces ese gráfico ya está hecho ya lo tiene tres de esos y lo
puedes usar lo puedes usar para hacer back test está mal usarlo no está mal usarlo vale no
está mal usarlo es el mejor bueno no mi opinión no por lo que os he dicho vale pero no está mal
no está mal usarlo si tú haces trabajas en él pues no es ningún drama no no no creo que llegues
a conclusiones erróneas por eso pero os explico os explico que son esas letras porque me lo
preguntabas ahí en tres sesiones existe la posibilidad de ajustar mediante
como tú como tú quieras igual que yo lo puedo hacer en tic data es un provee una
empresa que se dedica a eso y me da un software para hacerlo tres sesión tiene alguna capacidad
de ajustar cuando tú vas a meter símbolo en símbolo cap hay uno que se llama custom
ahí es donde tú haces el futuro personalizable nuevamente insisto mucho cuando hablaba de tres
sesión voy a hacerlo muy breve porque no va de tres sesiones esto os recomiendo siempre usar la
ayuda de tres sesiones porque es bastante potente en general la ayuda está bastante bien aquel que
no toque que no sepa ni papa de inglés pues lo selecciona lo lleva un traductor y se va con eso
pero pero la ayuda está en general en general bastante bien sigo entonces yo aquí en esa forma
pongo el símbolo en este caso en el q vale la del símbolo root que es la ruta puedo sino buscarla
en eq y ya me salen veis los vencimientos que tiene ese contrato solo me salen marcables marzo
septiembre junio y diciembre por cierto aquí es un sitio mira ahora os voy a poner el cl momentito
solo para que veáis que me los marca a todos aquí es un sitio donde si no os acordáis de las letras
bueno nos podéis encontrar en internet con mucha facilidad pero si no os acordáis aquí están aquí
están enero f febrero g marzo h es trimestral el más común abril j mayoca junio m nuevamente
trimestral julio n agosto q septiembre u trimestral octubre v noviembre x y diciembre zeta que es
el trimestral son los cuatro más usuales h m u zeta pero el petróleo por ejemplo los tiene todos
los tiene todos porque es el de cada mes entonces cada uno tiene el suyo esto como ya os expliqué
hay que saberlo al principio puede ser un lío pero esto es previo ya lo sabes y hasta ya lo sabes que
el petróleo de cada mes tú creas tu contrato el que quieras ya no lo vas a hacer más está hecho
parte de ahí ya es una rutina es una rutina entonces es un requisito podemos decir de
configuración por eso lo metí en aspectos previos porque es un tema de podemos decir el de setup
que tiene que ver con la tecnología con todo esto y a una vez ya sabido y tal pues ya para
antes no bien volvemos a la necu aquí me salen los cuatro marzo junio septiembre diciembre además
me salen algunas opciones para elegir cómo hago ese ajuste normal cuál eliges como contrato
ajustar normalmente el más cercano y si rola por actividad es decir cuando haya un día consecutivo
de mayor open interest o mayor volumen o por tiempo por actividad es lo correcto pero pero si
lo hiciera bien que tic data lo hace bien vale es eso no lo hace bien porque porque la regla esto
quiero que lo que lo entendáis no es que no lo haga no no es que lo haga no es que no lo haga
bien es que yo cuando sé si yo voy monitorizando el volumen contra el volumen de un contrato y del
siguiente de acuerdo en el momento en que yo detecte que el siguiente en este caso la situación
que real estamos operando con marzo el siguiente va a ser junio está lejos pero a medida que se
acerque el tercer viernes de marzo va a ir haciendo más volumen y va a llegar un día para llegar un
día antes del vencimiento antes del vencimiento que el contrato de junio va a empezar a hacer más
volumen que el de marzo eso va a pasar pocos días antes en ese momento cuando detecta que un día
tiene más volumen cambia vale pero eso que provoca que como ha detectado que hay un día más quiere
decir que lo hace un día tarde entendéis el motivo porque hasta que no pasa un día en que
hace más volumen no se da cuenta que hecho más volumen de esa manera en el continuo metes un día
con poco volumen esto es la práctica en la teoría lo enseñe aquí voy a intentar enseñarlo a ver si
me carga más o menos rápido me carga más o menos rápido es esta justa este de aquí
está y es de aquí vamos a hacerlo aquí lo vais a ver rápido en el de la izquierda de la
derecha vale porque el de la derecha está ajustado el de la izquierda está ajustado
pero por el de tres es está usado por el de tres vamos a volver a ponernos cerca esto era por
aquí era por aquí hay poca diferencia realidad porque en ese día en ese día todavía en este
contrato por ejemplo en algunos en que es más crítico en nq realmente en realidad
rolar en cinco o en seis días antes hasta en siete es bastante parecido porque son
contratos que hacen mucho volumen los de acciones tienen un rolo que dura casi toda la semana es
decir hay dos tres días de margen se me entienda hay un día que es óptimo porque es el día que
hay más volumen que es 5 5 días antes por eso habéis visto 105 ahora vuelvo a la ventanita
entonces aquí en el día en que hay el ajuste que se veía muy bien en el que en el que no
había volumen a ver déjamelo encontrar era aquí era uno de estos dos uno de estos dos a ver aquí
aquí yo tengo un volumen ellos lo voy a decir los voy a tener que creer porque no lo vais a ver
317 y 361 el día 11 317 el día 11 317 el día 12 371 no es antes este todavía están en el
mismo que sí que ha rolado antes ha rolado en este 21 15 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 por aquí 239 por aquí va a
ser 473 510 a 23 510 control aquí está no son 3 510 todavía están en el mismo 540 561
2 40 561 no es que es aquí es aquí lo veo ahora el día me cago en la leche no lo veo el día
ya os lo mostré otro día porque no lo veo voy a volver al continuo se me lo cargue rápido
esto lo tengo ya saturado normalmente cargaría bastante rápido cargaría bastante rápido pero
os lo que decía antes el servidor de tiempo real se satura cuando le verás mucho una cruz que
tenemos contra ese son hacia demasiado tiempo no es un audio no lo que pasa es que lo hablo
porque porque estoy o no no tengo audio como que no tengo audio no se me oye a vale vale si si si
si se me oye en la plataforma me dice que sí nada nada es el es el aquí esta marca 11 aquí está
aquí está el día entonces hay un día se me colaba por algún micro hay un diálogo que os
digo que refleja menos volumen de acuerdo este día el día del enlace refleja menos volumen el que
hace el que une tres station entonces esto no es tremendamente grave como os decía pero es más
óptimo usar el custo que nosotros lo hemos ido mirando hay momentos que era 5 en momentos que
era 6 y ahora mismo es 5 y si en algún momento 6 pues lo volveremos a cambiar simplemente es comparar
el día en que hay más volumen esto como os digo por uso y costumbre el mercado al final el mercado
siempre opera por uso y costumbre igual que por ejemplo en el dax el dax es el mismo día el dax
veces vence perdón el tercer viernes de mes igual pero que es a las 12 del mediodía entonces
es ese mismo día el rolo o sea al cierre del día anterior se cambia el contrato en cambio en
wall street siempre ha habido esta costumbre de venir haciéndolo desde 7 6 5 en estos en estos
días que es más o menos una semana antes vale una semana y entonces ahí en esos días tú puedes
entonces la unión si tú usas en que usas el valor por defecto lo peor del nq en sí el nq o
cualquier otro no es tampoco el día que como os digo aquí no es súper crítico sino el hecho
que usa valor absoluto vale ellos usan valor absoluto y por lo tanto a medida que ha ido
pasando el tiempo que han cambiado tanto los precios pues se nota se va notando se va notando
qué problema plantea ajustar por ratio o por qué ellos a lo mejor no lo hacen porque es verdad que
el decimal es otro tema que tenés que saber tú cómo el ajuste es por ratio es decir yo divido
o multiplico por 103 por ejemplo hemos visto que decir que los los precios anteriores al contrato
actual pues van a tener valores tipo 2450,14,92,68 es decir no va a respetar el valor del tic y por
eso hay gente que eso no le gusta nada y dice que eso plantea problemas que no es nada problemático
porque puedes usar el redondeo de hecho tres eso mismo ya lo hace ya redondea al tic siguiente es
decir no plantea problemas pero es buena práctica redondear por código y está y se redondea al tic
y punto no tiene mayor mayor e inconveniente vale pero no os volváis loco con esto si usáis el
que viene en tres eso por efecto está bien está bien no es ningún drama lo que pasa que quería
que quedara claro lo entendierais y vierais porque veis gráficos que pone 105 xn o 105 xc o 106 vale
lo que quiere decir es estas opciones de configuración que os he enseñado aquí en el lookup
si queréis os explico cada una pero es que de verdad no creo que valga que valga mucho la
pena sino porque es todo esto vale es decir el 5 es obvio es este 5 de cuántos días antes de la
expiración xc es cuando es valor absoluto y xr es cuando es por ratio y xn es sin ajuste vale es
decir es estas distintas opciones es lo que marcan esas letras y este número es lo que marca del
6 7 7 7 si le hubiera puesto activity entonces cambia es un día consecutivo de mayor volumen es
11 v o r puedes ver ese y si veis no han ajustado que mucha gente que prefieren ajustado pero eso
que os digo mi opinión rompes totalmente la relación bueno si lo controlas por código está
bien pero rompes la relación incluso de los de los indicadores y de todos tienes que tener en
cuenta eso porque es lo que lo que veíais aquí en el en el que tenían ajustado antes no en ese
gap esos 200 puntos de gap que habían ahí de pronto realmente si tú no controlas eso tienes 200
puntos ahí que aunque tú hayas cerrado y operado imagínate que tienes ahí una media móvil o
cualquier otra otro cálculo este esa media queda alterada ese valor o ese indicador es esto castigo
se ma que sé lo que tú quieras ese atr todo cualquier dato que se calcule con precios del
gráfico al final está alterado si utiliza datos de días anteriores que cualquiera lo hace nada más
que utilice un día anterior ese día tiene 200 puntos falsos de gap no tiene un precio mucho
mayor que no es real si no ajustas entiendes ese es el problema que plantea entonces lo correcto
es ajustar pero se pueden ajustar ya digo que en casos intradía donde se puede controlar y donde
imaginaros un open range breakout que haremos en el curso vale pues ahí podemos hacerlo en
ajustado porque porque yo voy a trabajar con datos del mismo día en la sesión y me da igual entonces
que los datos más prefiero prefiero analizar así tener los precios bien históricos pero entonces
no tengo que utilizar datos del día anterior entiende si utilizo datos del día anterior si
no ajusto estoy metiendo un posible error ahí posible error el problema principal no es tanto
que el backtess sea más es que le metes un sesgo al optimizador es decir si yo aquí yo aquí luego
voy a optimizar algo y aquí tengo 200 puntos de gap arriba voy a hacer que la optimiza el optimizador
va a hacer todo lo posible para no ponerse corto ahí se voy a meter o sea es verdad que aquí es
un vencimiento trimestral pero imaginaos el caso mensual no le voy a meter un sesgo a que evite
se evite a ir corto por toda costa porque si le meto 200 puntos de gap va a evitar entonces le voy
a meter un sesgo al optimizador un condicionante que encima no es real no es real entonces por
eso es mejor ajustar vale me queda algo alberto vale miro yo entonces vale están más o menos
caros si alguien tiene algo que escriba ahora sobre este tema porque lo iré cerrando donde indica
cómo han sido ajustados los datos no por defecto bueno o sea en el caso de tres por efecto ya te
digo en la roba en eq ajusta por diferencia esto pues se le ayuda cada plataforma o cada proveedor
de datos tendrá su documentación esto no tiene no hay un sitio de ir a mirar de acuerdo porque
esto al final es un tema de datos entonces el proveedor de datos el que tú cuando coges un
proveedor de datos pues tienes que mirarlo pues igual que tienes que mirar yo que sé si te compras
un coche y te importa pues yo que sé la especificación del motor del coche pues tienes que mirar por
ejemplo es que mirar si le pones gasolina o le pones diésel o le pones pues eléctrico si le
pones gasolina y va con dice ya por no sé le pones diésel pues te cargas el motor entonces
la final son especificaciones y está tienes que ir a buscarlas al proveedor al proveedor de los
datos pero nuevamente es un tema de configuración que una vez ya he sabido pues ya está ya he sabido
ya sabes los condicionantes que tienes y no os volváis locos digo lo que quería es que lo
lo entendierais vale en cuanto a los etf es es decir esto es en caso del futuro que es el
caso más evidente en casos de tf es también podéis encontrar también podéis encontrar que
algún proveedor ajuste también podéis encontrar que algún proveedor ajuste pero
a ver un momento me encuentro esto rápido voy a buscarlo aquí os muestro os muestro un poco
pero breve esto es breve ya cerramos esto voy voy voy voy voy voy voy voy contestada donde indica
cómo han sido bueno repite alberto si si eso eso estaba ahora con eso donde indica preguntaba
el donde indica cómo se han ajustado los datos no no esto ya lo comentaba tiene que
buscarlo en el proveedor ya está esto ya está esto ya está ya está respondido ahora tendrá una
de miguel hay larguita bueno en el caso de los de los etf u acciones vale ahí ya no hay tanta
problemática porque no hay este efecto porque el origen de estos repito es que hay vencimientos
las acciones no tienen vencimiento por lo tanto no hay este problema en las acciones que puede haber
puede haber el pago de los dividendos que ahí hay más menos consenso y pago de los dividendos o
de los cupones vale de los cupones también los split o ajustes o contra split este tipo vale
pero os enseño el tdt porque ese es el caso más paradigmático realmente tres eso no lo ajusta vale
y eso hace que realmente tenga un valor muy inferior al que debería al que debería perdón
para reflejar el valor de una inversión en el tnt eso que debería reflejar un índice entonces
esto ahí hay un etero debate esto es más correcto aquí ya es más debatible y no perdemos más el
tiempo porque hay bastante opinión sobre que no hay que hacerlo yo creo que sería mejor hacerlo
creo que sería mejor hacerlo pero es verdad que no es dramático no hacerlo no es dramático no
hacer porque aquí no hay no es el mismo efecto es una es un valor monetario que sale te pagan el
dividendo y tú lo cobras entonces la acción sigue cotizando bueno pero también se descuenta
hay proveedores que permiten ajustarlo hay proveedores que permiten ajustar ese pago de
ese pago de dividendos también os lo digo por si lo veis si lo veis alguien nos quiere preguntar
pues que nos pregunta pero como nosotros en este caso no lo vamos a tratar específicamente no
dedico más tiempo encargas tú de lo de miguel alberto que vale entonces si no hay más de este
tema doy por doy por cerrado el tema el tema este vale vamos a hacer un breve de ser pero antes
antes del descanso planteo un poco planteo un poco la primera estrategia que vamos a trabajar hoy
no la vamos a trabajar entera vamos a plantearla vamos a explicarla vamos a desarrollar el inicio
porque la quiero plantear la quiero plantear un poco como hemos planteado la teoría de acuerdo
es decir los perfiles de entradas salidas filtros vale porque luego además también hay alguna
pregunta relacionado con esto y también hablaré un poco de esto también usando ese sistema y
usando algún otro para responder alguna alguna pregunta que nos han hecho lo aprovecharé que
es un poco la idea vale entonces simplemente lo voy a plantear cómo hemos empezado porque había
hay otro de los eternos delante y eso sí que vamos a hacer varias clases varias clases y por
varios métodos vale la búsqueda de ideas de acuerdo es un tema que creo que siempre preocupa
y ocupa y de hecho ahí es seguramente el motivo por el que triunfan tanto estos programitas de
buscador de esta tesis cuanta alfa todos estos programas que sirven para para empezar la casa
por el tejado mejor de empezar a casa por el tejado vale cuando realmente hay muchas ideas
disponibles y no hace falta no hace falta hay muchas maneras de contarlas vale y iremos iremos
viendo muchas y a la teoría habéis visto algunas vamos a empezar por la por alguna que ya ha salido
en el curso y que hemos hablado mucho de ellos de que ya os dije que haríamos y que no va a ser
el único de más no va a ser el único sistema que vamos que vamos a usar este lo vamos a usar
para hacerlo crecer de hecho en esta versión prelimina vale este sistema sigue una vela de entrada
tipo doncha de acuerdo tipo doncha una entrada tipo doncha no es más que una ruptura de canal
vale de doncha he hablado mucho empecé hablando incluso en la historia en la historia del
límico recordáis y hablamos de los canales de doncha por los canales ya os dije siguen totalmente
en vigor y hablar mucho de ellos y ya veis que es el primer sistema que os presento que es un canal
de doncha bueno esa rayita en este caso lo he hecho con cierres ya veremos de otra manera porque
se puede hacer con cierres se puede hacer por máximos vale voy a poner el grado está el gráfico
en velas lo voy a poner otra vez como bien me ha dicho alberto antes que se vea porque así
no se ve un carajo vale entonces ahí vale y lo voy a pasar a línea para que veáis que efectivamente
lo que valoramos son cierres por encima de el carácter vale son en el momento en que el precio
cierra por encima del máximo en este caso de 10 cierres esto es apel en velas diarias
eso se apel en velas diarias ya veremos ahora cómo lo valoró pero esto es una idea tan sencilla como
esta y de dónde viene esta cosa os la he explicado en el curso vale esta viene pero es que es mega
otra conocida canal de canal de doncha no se lo habéis podido ver en 300 libros revistas decir
sale en todos los sitios es decir no tiene no tiene mucho a la fuente es que es hasta no sé
cuál es la fuente porque es que hay tanta o sea es algo tan común un canal de doncha que no sé
cuál es la fuente de verdad si ahora vosotros buscáis canal de doncha mira voy a probarlo canal
de doncha en internet nos sale un montón que es un canal de doncha y nos sale un artículo mío muy
a mí era este arranque cual es mío no no es de miguel arias bueno es que hay un montón
mira me quedo con este se quedó con ese bueno si hay hay apretadas un indicador técnico el
límite trazado líneas de precio el líneas superior línea inferior por defecto 22 acordéis que os lo
dije 20 días pero bueno pues bueno pues le podemos 20 le ponemos 20 igual me lo voy a poner 20
y así vamos por defecto de entrada vale el canal de 20 aquí también le voy a poner 20 al canal
de cierres que es el indicador que he hecho para pintarlo y vamos con 20 días 20 días tiene además
una salida por tiempo y tiene de momento un stop y te pe sí meten no sé cuánto le he puesto no
no he hecho nada en ocho ningún proceso de utilización nada es cero la verdad le había puesto 10
10 le he puesto que le he puesto un 10 por ciento un 10 por ciento es que voy en diario si un 10
por ciento de esto 10 por ciento de y salida en 10 barras vale y si le pongo muchas más barras
vamos a ver si actúa tp simétrico tal me voy a poner 100 barras simplemente para que no actúe lo
podía haber configurado no creo que no lo he hecho para que si siempre salga bueno no pues mira aquí
no sale ni por esto ni por tp sale por por las barras por las barras y les tope 500
ahora no sabes esto por código lo podríamos haber hecho mejor pero ahí se sale y es así que sigue
comprado entonces ahora he obligado a que salga por stop y tp de un 10 por ciento este metado se
han hecho ningún proceso de utilización ni nada estoy en una fase completamente inicial de la idea
tengo ya alguna cosa metida en el código para luego explicaros la porque ya la he hecho pero
están comentadas y no igual ahora mismo no no importa esto ya os lo como os dije cuando los
códigos vayan evolucionando los daré el sudo código hoy lo vamos a prácticamente plantear
prácticamente y hablar un poco de él entenderlo y demás y lo iremos validando aprovecho aprovecho
una viene ligado con una pregunta que ha habido en el discord que iba relacionado con esto con la
validación de entradas se descartaban ideas no se descartaban que era bastante bastante interesante
interesante había alguien ahí que decía que se apuntaba se lo recuerdo mal
hablaba un poco que tenía un setup hablaba porque tenía un setup tendencial y que le daba un
porcentaje de aciertos muy bajos y eso lo descartaba el sistema el problema es que
decía que él si eso implicaba que tenía poca ventaja estadística recordar recordar una cosa
vale un porcentaje de acierto en sí por si no dice nada no dice nada cuando dije que esto
que es verdad que lo dije en la teoría y quizá pues quizá no no quedó suficientemente claro que
puede ser una manera de validar una estrategia de entrada es partiendo de un siguiente condicionante
partiendo de que yo igualo es decir acordaros de que la esperanza matemática por daros que
la esperanza matemática pero no es más que acordaros lo voy a enseñar del powerpoint
donde está esto esto es muy importante ahora no lo estoy encontrando esto aquí esperanza
esperanza siguiente siguiente siguiente aquí aquí donde te estás ahora no aquí perfecto vale esto
era la diapositiva de esperanza vale esta era la esperanza ruina acordaros daros que la esperanza
más sencilla por así acuerdo que es al final no es más que el porcentaje de aciertos por el payoff
menos el porcentaje de pérdidas vale si yo tengo un win voy a intentar una osadía
nos haría cuidado que aquellos que me conocen saben mis capacidades de dibujo pero vamos a ver
cuidado a ver 0 50 pero 50 vale si yo voy a si yo tengo stop y tp voy a un payoff de 1 menos
pero 50 esto que da venga no me hace falta coger la calculadora para saber que esto da
0,0 vale esto da 0 vale 0 vale es decir un sistema con porcentaje de acierto 50% y mismo
ganancia de media por tre ganador que lo que pierde por el perdedor de acero vale por tanto
haciendo esa similación borro haciendo esa misma analogía puedo deducir que si yo igualo
si yo igualo el tp si yo hago que el tp sea igual al stop loss esto estaremos de acuerdo
bueno estoy empeorando por momentos estaremos de acuerdo que esto da más o menos un payoff de 1
que no va a ser exacto porque habrá veces que salde por el sistema por lo que sea pero esto
va a dar un payoff de 1 vale ergo si eso es así si tengo más de un 50% de aciertos el sistema
tiene esperanza positiva si yo tengo más de un 50% se entiende tengo un payoff una esperanza
positiva y de ahí es donde parte esa idea se entiende de decir que una manera sencilla a
veces de evaluar un setup de entrada directo es decir bueno si yo igualo stop y tp acierta
más de la mitad entonces volviendo a la pregunta que me hacíais que había más de una en esta línea
pero una que hacía alejandro en disco vale decía decía que estaba poniendo en práctica voy a
resumir aunque sea el disco la podéis leer aquellos aquellos que tenéis acceso al disco
que sus todos los alumnos pues el disco vale decía justamente eso que yo había comentado lo
del win rate del 50% vale que no ha realizado la prueba pero que él lo había puesto la condición
de entrada como salida igual vale esto no es lo mismo que yo he dicho porque esto te puede
llevar a un por taje de aciertos más bajo y por lo tanto un payoff muy alto esto es correcto él
decía de hecho que le pasaba decía que le daba una esperanza muy buena perfecto pues está bien
pero eso no eso no es lo que lo que decía me acuerdo lo que decía es que si tú tenías el
tú igualabas payoff o sea mantenías payoff 1 vale que es mismo riesgo que ganancia uno a uno esto hay
traders por ejemplo que lo hacen muchos seres excepcionales que van uno a uno es una manera
muy intuitiva por lo que os digo porque digo bueno yo voy uno a uno porque sé que si acierto
más del 50 ya está si yo sé que tengo una ventaja que soy capaz de hacer entradas de más
de un 50 por ciento de acierto voy uno a uno es decir a riesgo lo mismo que ganan un 1% de
esto 1% de tp se entiende esa es una manera fácil de evaluar la entrada pero volviendo a
la pregunta alejandro no es exactamente lo mismo él me decía tiene un win rate del 30% para largo
y un 30 para el corto pero él había hecho salida por la contra del sistema con eso no igual a
riesgo y beneficio de acuerdo esa condición no está cumpliendo esto vale no está manteniendo
un payoff no está manteniendo un payoff de 1 no está manteniendo un payoff pues mucho más
alto mucho más alto mejor de 2 a 1 entonces claro un rate bajo lógico una cosa va con la otra si
el payoff es más alto el win rate baja el win rate es muy alto el payoff es casi siempre inseparable
ya os lo dije sistemas tendenciales tienen un porcentaje de aciertos bajo pero todavía tienen
un payoff bastante alto y viceversa sistemas antitenenciales tienen un win por un percentage
de aciertos bastante elevado y entonces tienen un win un payoff bastante bajo las dos cosas van
combinadas y lógicamente la entrada y la salida por eso ya os lo hablé que en teoría que no
siempre lo vamos a hacer así es decir ya os lo comenté pero yo quise explicaros es decir por eso
a las prácticas para luego ver cómo lo aplicamos todo porque la teoría yo os quise explicar lo que
hacemos y también os expliqué más cosas de las que hacemos es así es decir porque queríamos darle
una base de como es el fundamento de conocimiento profundo de todo lo que creemos que es importante
y incluso ya digo hay cosas como no sé ahora me viene a caso el bra no donde yo no comulgo mucho
pero yo os expliqué también y la intentaremos enseñar un curso es decir al final hay que
hay que explicarlo todo entonces espero que con esto quede claro que alejandro quede respondido
entonces la pregunta el que hacía al final es descartarías de una al sistema porque el setup
de entraba no tiene ventaja estadística no es que no es verdad que no tiene ventaja estadística
alejandro no es verdad que no tiene ventaja estadística o sea el planteamiento que has hecho
sin correcto es decirle ya es normal que un sistema puede tener un rate de 30% o tiene eso
en sí no es nada malo pero verás que tiene un pay off muy alto entonces ahí está si quieres
evaluar la entrada sola tienes que tener pay off de uno ese es el truco vale para evaluar y no
cumple y no hacer todo un proceso sino de una manera rápida la evaluación preliminar que esto
luego luego luego cuando entre más profundidad las preguntas sólo aprovecha un poco porque me
venía al pelo con el sistema que es lo que voy a tratar de ir haciendo aprovechar lógicamente
lo que explicamos para para ir aprovechando para añadir material de acuerdo este es un
poco la idea entonces aprovechando que ese sistema ya lo voy a aprovechar pues de entrada lo he
creado con 1 1 lo he creado con 1 1 y ahora le he sacado la salida por tiempo y lo he dejado con
1 1 lo he dejado con 1 1 y sólo va largo y luego ya lo veremos para hacer corto también ya lo veremos
0 1 0 1 en apple y esto que me da una evaluación preliminar podemos decir esto que me da esto me
da esto va lentísimo esto me da que no sé cómo le puse de setup mil dólares de momento no tiene
costes porque esto en acciones plantea un problema luego tiene un porcentaje de aciertos del 61 por
ciento y en un porcentaje de 61 por ciento veis este es un ejemplo de lo que os decía yo le he
igualado el riesgo y tp actúa los dos parece que sí que actúan los dos porque si no actuar no
tendría sentido debería bajarlo lo vamos a hacer hay que ver que los dos actúen bastante porque
si no me estoy engañando es un poco alto vamos a bajarlo ahora vamos a bajarlo pero sí que se ve
bueno actúa porque no puede salir de otra manera de hecho perdón si acabo de dejar que le he
quitado el le he quitado el factor temporal es decir todo el rato sale por o por tp por esto
o sea todo el rato sale por tp por esto claro va solo largo o sea este es muy fácil esta ventaja
es decir no hombre si tienes razón es fácil porque esto es solo largo pero bueno lo usado para
explicaros y no quiere decir sea el hecho de que sea una ventaja ir largo no es algo malo
o sea en bolsa no es algo malo es algo que podemos aprovechar a nuestro favor no se trata de decir
nosotros trataremos de aprovechar eso en nuestro favor de hecho y ya los lo ya os lo enseñé en el
en la teoría pero lógicamente una de las cosas que también quiero enseñaros hoy y a partir de
ahora en esta parte que vamos a entrar en estos sistemas que vamos a hacer varios nos dije en la
muchos tipos pero os dije que vamos a empezar por el perfil más tranquilo vale y que es el
que perfil que le llamamos no perfil aquel de operador que tiene otro trabajo y que solo puede
operar por las tardes y que no quiere dedicar muchas horas al día de acuerdo pero es que ese
perfil que perfil que es el que yo recomiendo empezar si tienes poca experiencia también debes
tener sistemas operando aquí si tienes experiencia y nosotros tenemos de acuerdo o sea nosotros
tenemos o sea que te quiero decir que este perfil no quiere decir que si tienes mucha experiencia
todo lo vas a operar interdiario porque al final si queremos un porfolio queremos diversificar las
maneras por estrategias necesitas hay que tener estrategias este tipo todos los perfiles entonces
empezamos por este porque este sí que es verdad que es para todo el mundo y es en el que recomendamos
empezar y el que recomendamos abordar algo límico antes en este tipo de estrategias porque
son estrategias más universales más fáciles de validar etcétera etcétera y lo iremos viendo pero
sirven para todo el mundo también los perfiles más activos está bien que tengáis estrategias que
van en un minuto si son rentables y las habéis validado pero la mejor diversificación que
podéis hacer es meter alguna diaria porque sabéis que seguramente conseguís
descorrelación entonces aquí lógicamente tenemos un activo que ha subido un poco
subido un poquito desde 0 30 hasta 190 y por lo tanto por un sistema largo pues tiene bastante
ventaja tiene bastante ventaja de hemos cargado de bastante atrás para que tuviera sus problemas
y demás pero lógicamente pues tiene tiene tiene bastante terreno terreno a favor y hay que
venga ese ratio tal importante por lo tanto donde está donde nos podemos
referenciar bueno en este caso en este tipo de acciones nuestro ve perdón en ese tipo de
sistemas nuestro mínimo benchmark es el vayanjol hemos acuerdo no es decir si yo no soy capaz de
batir al vayanjol pues se apaga apague vámonos entonces ahí es donde metemos
un momento que nos estoy montando aquí abajo cuánto capital había puesto aquí sí sí por encima
sí enseñar a enseñar el código un momentito ahora ahora lo enseño mejor pero pero bueno no
me quiero perder mucho código porque al final no por todas las ideas más que el código pero sí
ahora lo voy a explicar con el código con el código y el lunes que viene que trabajaremos
esta estrategia en profundidad si no yo os la quiero plantear como quería empezar con el otro
y sabía que no me daría tiempo a acabarla pues no quiero quiero plantearla y ahora responder
preguntas y el lunes que viene la trabajaremos de acuerdo ya dejaré algo más preparado por si
lo acabo que no creo porque hay mucho que trabajar porque no es esta esa esos su evolución sus filtros
su derivada es decir vamos a vamos a componer la estrategia esta vamos a tratar de hacer una
estrategia con ella con sus posibles alternativas y la vamos a evaluar de las maneras que podamos
evaluarla una estrategia de este tipo que lo veremos lo veremos ya os comenté que lógicamente
hay hay diferencia y que no es no siempre vamos a poder aplicar un wall forward completo a todas
estrategias no siempre vamos a poder utilizar toda esta metodología lógicamente a medida que se
nos que la frecuencia operativa es menor pues se va complicando pero lo vamos a lo vamos a probar
vamos a probar y vamos a ver qué qué conclusiones sacamos no quiero anticiparme que me cuesta frenarme
pero bueno esta es la esa es la curva del sistema en sí que lo había diseñado con mil dólares
empezando a ver lo voy a poner aquí en dólares estoy haciendo un back test de
vaya con él aquí abajo ahora os lo enseño os lo enseño voy a poner mil dólares
y esto empecé el 29 en el 99 hasta el 29 bueno está hasta hoy bueno pues nada
voy a poner hasta ayer hasta ayer perfecto y como le malas mentenía
y por cien por cien pues vamos con él aquí vamos a ver eso si lo hecho bien esta es la curva
lo hecho en el spy en apple podría haberlo hecho en apple también que se habrá estado mejor
a nivel de ejemplo ya nos ya nos sirve aquí de hecho en apple habrá sido todo más crítico
el que tenemos que va cerca del 50 por ciento y bueno pues tenemos ahí unos unos datos entonces
esto es lo que usaremos un poco de comparativa lo mínimo por supuesto lo mínimo que hay que
que hay que hacer es batir a esto o pasarte mínimo entonces usaremos de comparativa benchmark
y luego también el mismo activo por el mismo activo en el activo ya lo haremos como os digo
el próximo el próximo día pero bueno aquí ya vemos que con ese sistema hemos sacado cuatro mil
dólares hemos yendo también a cien por ciento creo que aquí tampoco tengo exposición pero
lo voy a meter ahora es bueno es que tengo que hacerla tengo que hacer la porcito pero
vamos a hacer una pausita vamos a hacer una pausita de cinco minutos tenga todo el mundo
entre ellos yo tiempo a ir un poquito un momentito a lavado si lo requiere y vuelvo en teoría mira
sabes que voy a hacer voy a dejar de compartir la pantalla sale eso sale la carotulita ahí y para
el día siguiente tenía un reloj pero como cambie de pc no tengo el reloj para el día siguiente a
ver si lo consigo pues había un reloj aquí en la pantalla que tendría que poner para no lo pongo
vuelvo ya digo ocho y dos ocho y tres espero aquí no sé si para la grabación no no la paro la paro
pero no me pone pausa me pone parar si la paro luego me arranca o que no sé no no la cuenta
no tengo pausa la grabación vale la puedo pausar venga la pausa la pausa venga pues
estamos de vuelta a este de este mini escarzo vale bien estaba aquí preparando
estaba preparando el de apple a ver si estaba mirando por eso que había puesto el capital
y ha puesto un inicio de mil no aquí también y ya están ahora fecha me interesa la fecha y
ahora he visto alguna pregunta ahí respecto a vallanjol ahora ahora os contesto os contesto
21 de enero del 99 para eso da igual porque no no va no va a trabajar pasar otro por encima
a ver el vallanjol mínimo cuando se ha hecho el se ha dicho sobre todo para sistemas de
medio de medio largo plazo que van en ese tiro lo mínimo lo mínimo lógicamente es
batido vallanjol en qué índice bueno en el sb puede estar bien pero si no en su acción
vale si no en su acción aquí le he puesto gestión monetaria equivocado 100% equivocado 100% porque
le he metido 2900 acciones le he metido 2900 acciones y cuando se empieza el primer trade
no es eso ya perfecto ya es eso bueno lo normal es en el índice aunque lógicamente te tienes que
comparar también con el activo en que vas en este caso vamos con una acción y lo que ahora mismo
no nos importan tanto los datos estamos viendo protocolos esto es una locura estamos dando una
acción que estaba 0 32 690 es completamente absurdo lo que ha ganado no tiene ningún tipo
ningún tipo de sentido pero pero es igual quedémonos con la idea de que evidentemente
lo haremos con el ratio de retorno riesgo porque habrá muchas veces en este tipo de sistemas lo vais
a ver en que no me refiero a este en otros en que el mensual o sea el vallanjol nos ganará más ganará
más que nosotros por un sistema pero a qué riesgo es decir este es el tema siempre que nos
nos interesa y que tenemos que ver tenemos que ver a ver a qué a qué riesgo lo hacemos para ello
acciones a 0 34 y las cierro el último día vale porque es como funciona este código de vallanjol y
claro pues me da un retorno pues un poquito alto un poquito pero pero ya está es simplemente
simplemente un ejemplo claro esto es a costa de tener un drawdown del 87% 83% de rodón no está mal
y a ver la exposición está bien esto ya lo iremos a bajando más si bueno está un poquito
pasado de siempre lo sabes entonces es esta sería una de las comparaciones que duda cabe con el
índice con el activo en que operas con la que operas pasa que aquí ya digo la dimensiónamiento
el dimensiónamiento es tremendamente tramposo porque aquí es verdad que empezamos con 2000
y no cojo no acumulo tantos ya veremos qué cambios le vamos haciendo a este sistema y
cómo cómo lo validamos etcétera simplemente quería plantearos lo y ahora os enseño el
código vale ahora os enseño el código cuál es la idea de este este sencillísimo sistema
vamos a ver hasta qué punto pues aprovechamos lo aprovechamos creo que sí que lo aprovecharemos
pero vamos a tener que trabajarlo está en esta configuración inicial es tremendamente básico y
tendrá que crecer un poco vale ahora mismo cómo funciona vale para aquellos que tendáis un poquito
los que no simplemente quedar con la explicación no es lo el código en sí no es más que una
explicación de la idea que ya os he dado que es aquí le he quitado el filtro de volatilidad
simplemente le he configurado que compre si el cierre es mayor o igual que el mayor cierre
estaba entendido lo hemos puesto en lo hemos puesto en el mayor cierre que el máximo cierre
de los últimos 20 días es esto y cierra por encima o igual al mismo precio que el máximo cierre de
los últimos 20 días compra y le hemos puesto que cierre de momento sólo para ver la evaluación del
set up rápida simétricamente simétricamente con un tp y esto creo que era del 10 del 10 por ciento
había contemplado que ya os lo comenté con muchas veces esto suele ir bien salidas temporales es
una salida que recomiendo bastante porque no tiene sentido estar indefinidamente en el mercado
esperando al acuerdo de estar en el mercado es por el riesgo hay que salir si no se cumple
nuestro objetivo en 10 verlas yo salvo que se cumple pues bien que no de esta manera
fijaros que casi siempre sale por tiempo bueno seguramente el esto bien te prestan un poquito
elevados es prácticamente así no actúa nunca aquí ahora mismo hemos hecho ningún análisis
no hemos hecho nada en todo esto y la verdad no lo he hecho ya no he mirado nada todavía
vale no he mirado nada no lo he estudiado simplemente lo he metido en lo creado
sé que un dungeon es una estrategia que puede que puede funcionar en muchos activos y esto
sin más y lo he metido y es pues ahí lo iremos viendo pero lo he metido en apple no lo podía
haber metido en otra acción lo he metido tengo por aquí una cosa vamos a ver esto
vamos a así que estamos viendo que el esto bien te ve ahí no actúan vamos a ponerle
que no tiene ni por qué ser simétricos lo normal es ser un activo tendencial es que le
dejáramos a la mejor este y el esto le dejáramos 2 a 1 esto era sólo por probar si te acertaba
más de un 50 por ciento en aquel ejemplo que los enseñaba vale ahora le hemos dejado el tp y el
esto que esto luego ya veremos que lo configuraremos así una posterior versión le haremos un
multiplicador del tp en base al esto 1 2 pero bueno en esta fase inicial pues bueno tenemos
un sistema muy básico que simplemente en tantas rupturas de encierres por encima del cierre de
hace 10 velas y bueno de 20 perdón y por lo tanto pues ya veis cómo se va se va incorporando
con algunos también estrepitosos fallos y tiene ahí sus sus entradas tenemos a menudas estrategias
que tienen reentradas tras salidas rápidas veremos varias cosas este es sólo un primer
planteamiento muy básico de algo de un mecanismo que ya habíamos visto en el curso que seguro que
habéis oído hablar si no habéis oído hablar pues ya os he enseñado antes este breve y podéis
buscar mil referencias sobre un canal de de ocho de acuerdo es una entrada lógicamente tendencial
de ruptura vale puede hacerse tendencial pura es decir como lo estamos planteando no no aquí pura
pero a tratar de dejar de correr o puede ser incluso a tp es muy cercanos para coger poco
movimientos explosivos y rápidos ya veremos que podemos meterle filtros de volatilidad
sigo ligando este planteamiento de este sistema que trabajaremos el próximo día en profundidad con
alguna de las preguntas a ver espérate a ver que ratios me ha dejado ahora es ahora al hacer este
dos a uno como hemos modificado mucho el porcentaje de aciertos pues acordáis que antes teníamos un
60 ahora ya tenemos un 51 pero claro ahora ya ganamos más de lo que perdemos tenemos una media
de lo que ganamos aquí lo tengo tenemos una vera que ni del hostia perdón adiós ha pasado hostia no
no perdón perdón yo si he apretado un botón pensaba que se me había colgado el ordenador
aquí estoy aquí tenemos una veras winning el 61 y una veras losing del 49 55 queda una media
es decir ya tenemos un 124 tenemos un 124 a ver a poner el tiempo que viene muy bien esto
tenemos un 124 que lo veis lo que era antes uno ahora es 124 entonces ya hemos bajado un
poquito por un acierto el sistema si está muy justito tirando el sistema si está tirando a
virria cuidado simplemente hemos hecho un planteamiento inicial hemos hecho un planteamiento
si está tirando a virria y esto está colgado no te creo vamos aguanta el sistema si está tirando
a ver la caída es decir vamos a ver cómo lo evolucionamos a partir de aquí simplemente
hemos hecho un primer planteamiento acuerdo vale ahora sí que voy ya con las con las preguntas
he respondido en parte una en parte una aunque había alguna más relacionada con éste que
profundizaban ello sí que tenía otro cruce de medias aquí igual vale porque porque ese era un
caso un para acabar de complementar esto que os he enseñado tenía aquí el típico cruce de medias
que usamos en el curso y os enseñé el cruce dorado pero lo puesto en 60 minutos vale para
que operara más simplemente aquí probablemente no es rentable y le he metido simplemente un
estopio tp simétrico vale el porcentaje es media compra y compra en cruces la media de 50 200
acordaros los señores crucedoros simplemente no importa es simplemente para enseñarles lo que
os decía de la evaluación te sentamos entrada o este truco de que tienen que acertar más del 50
por ciento y en este caso le he puesto un esto y te pide dos y dos y medio vale porque lo he
puesto un poco más alto ahora los subiré antes pero claro actúa muy poco actúa muy poco y es lo
que decía necesitamos que actúe y aquí que hemos que hemos conseguido hemos conseguido que el sistema
sea una virria en sí de acuerdo pero bueno no es también es virre no es una virre enorme tenemos
ya 53 por ciento de acierto en una porque porque os he querido poner esto porque una
sistema con cruce de medias de entrada es tendencia por antonomasia de acuerdo es lo
más tendencial que hay decir y a esto si lo dejo correr y no le pongo tp y este tiene por
ventaja de aciertos bajísimo por lo bajísimo pero al meterle tp y stop simétrico fijaros que lo
he subido del 50 casi lo dejaba antitenencial porque porque las salidas de acuerdo es lo que
marcan mucho sigo un poco con la con el con este comentario de alejandro que luego había alguien
más también que en el disco insistía en ello que quería que profundizará sobre sobre esto vale al
final las salidas lo que le marca mucho le marca mucho porque yo lógicamente no es al 100 por
100 uno vale no es al 100 por ciento no dejaros que es más de uno y todo cosa que aún va más a
favor del sistema es 107 el ratio porque porque al final aunque yo le ponga tp y esto hay algunos
tres que salen por la propia cruce de la media y no todos el 100% de los tres van a salir por
por esa condición entonces aún así fijaros que yo he conseguido un average with loss de 107 creo
que no hay comisiones pero aquí da igual y he conseguido un portaje de acierdos por encima
de 53 es decir tengo una esperanza positiva ahora mismo vale con una simple cruce de medias y un
estope igualado lado largo otra vez el activo es hombre es que el activo y allá pero por eso funciona
ya lo sé pero es que que hayan que hayan condiciones como que un activo tenga mucha tendencia se ha
lanzado la baja no quiere decir que yo no pueda aprovecharla de acuerdo hemos que aprovecharla
mejor no os quedéis por favor con los resultados que estamos viendo que no importan para nada
ahora mismo son una birria de acuerdo es decir simplemente estoy respondiendo al requisito de
evaluar el requisito de si el win rate del 50 por ciento era condición necesaria para valor
una entrada no es que sea condición necesaria sino que es verdad que es un truco rápido muchas
veces en algunos setups mirar este en setups incluso entre a diarios igualar casi que os
diría donde va mejor es en entre a diarios decir si en un setup rápido yo puedo evaluar si si ese
tiene sentido yo igual los top y tp y tiene que aceptar más de la mitad de las veces el cuerpo
tiene que aceptar más porque si no realmente no hay ventaja también había una pregunta ligada
con esto que decía bueno entonces si es menos de 50 no vale el sistema no no lo diría al 100
por ciento pero es verdad que empiezas con un handicap vale es verdad pero puedes o sea las
salidas podrían recuperar esa desventaja así que podría ser o sea las salidas son muy importantes
realmente es importante todo pero siempre hay autores que defienden que la entrada es que la
salida para mí no hay duda que es la salida lo más lo que condiciona claramente carácter del
sistema y eso que os digo ahora esto luego lo que me todo salió aquí entrando así modificó
las salidas de cambio totalmente el sistema no cambio totalmente modificando la salida es decir
pero evidentemente también así por la entrada y una manera fácil repito de evaluar esto es esta
cosa sobre todo sobre todo especialmente útil en entrar especialmente útil en entraría y ya
lo veremos a medida que avancemos en la complicación del curso iremos viendo todos
los procesos desde la manera más fácil luego las iremos complicando más complicado es lo que os
decía y ahora que pongo 05 no 05 no 05 es 50 por ciento pero 5 60 minutos es esto 5 por ciento es
esto le he puesto un 5 por ciento y ya deja correr un poquito más y estamos en 49 se nos
ha caído ya del 50 nos ha caído pero a cambio fijaros que ha hecho el win-loss 1 60 y está el
tema dice si tú ves un 49 invalida hombre pero no ves que tienen 1 60 no está siendo no está
saliendo simétrico no está ganando lo mismo que lo que pierde gana 3 80 pero es 26 porque porque
el stop salta menos entonces al final no está actuando lo suficiente para para para que eso
tenga sentido tienes que igualar el retorno el riesgo y esto lo va a decir el ratio win-loss
de acuerdo te lo va a decir el ratio win-loss creo que ha quedado claro este punto no vale entonces
había alguna pregunta más he comentado no sí creo que sí a ver aquí habían algunas preguntas
en discord vale hablaban sobre ahora voy repasando un poco y voy leyéndolos como son públicas
lo que era aureli preguntaba sobre el vídeo de evaluación preliminar y hemos hablado un poco
de ello porque ya trato de aprovecharlo y hemos hablado un poco de ello decía que que métrica
usamos para decidir si pasa la evaluación o no en una evaluación preliminar básicamente se trata
que la idea tenga ventaja es esto que estamos viendo ahora un poco aureli vale el que la idea
tenga una cierta ventaja sin haber forzado mucho las cosas fíjate yo ahora te he puesto esto sencillo
tonchar media tal y a partir de ahí podemos ver si trabajamos idealmente en varios activos idealmente
sobre todo en este tipo de sistemas tiene que ser en varios activos en este tipo de sistemas
tiene que ser en varios activos y ahora aquí esto lo tenía antes en apple lo he hecho que lo iba
a hacer de hecho y no lo no lo he hecho le ponemos poner por ejemplo google y tenemos que ver que tal
funciona lo ideal sería que en diversos activos nos mantuviera un poquito tipo repito que estamos
ahora bueno no sé si ahora estoy no ahora no espérate voy a volver al setup anterior voy a
volver al setup anterior voy a volver a anular la salida por tiempo vale un poquito está está no
lo he iniciado antes no lo he iniciado antes en la pausa y evidentemente me he equivocado porque
está sufriendo ya lo que nos ha escrito lo voy a igualar esto ahora cuando era 05 vamos a poner
05 con don chan a 20 menos que a 20 le doy un poco más de margen